[Musik]
herzlich Willkommen zu vogm Tag 1 heute
versuche ich in einem Tag Skifahren zu
lernen im snowdome
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Bispingen wir haben uns jetzt
reingeschlichen und als erstes müssen
wir uns natürlich umziehen und skiequip
ausleihen so ich gehe jetzt einmal in
die Zauberkugel rein und dann sehen wir
uns gleich
wieder
ich bin so aufgeregt dass ich auf Klo
gehen könnte aber jetzt mit diesem Anzug
ist es sehr schwer ich freue mich aber
extrem weil wenn ihr das noch nicht
wisst ich liebe Schnee ich liebe es wir
haben ja gerade draußen das Intro ne ha
hallo im Regen gemacht in einer Stunde
soll es draußen einen Schneesturm geben
der über 5 Stunden geht und jetzt sind
wir aber schon mal hier drin und kriegen
so Vorgeschmack auf Winter auf Schnee
auf a zum
verle also ich muss einmal skie skie
ausleihen Ski und Schuhe ja und das war
erstmal das fühlt sich richtig krass an
das ist also so ein fettes
Teil ja vielen Dank
ne
ho lauf ich läuft man so da drin sieht
das so aus ist es normal was du gerade
siehst ist auch das ist schönste Tag in
deinem Leben ne jetzt liest
du pass auf dass ich erschft
[Musik]
bin guck die Leute
GU sind aber viel
los
was habe ich mir hier nur eingebrockt
jetzt mal ganz ernsthaft das ist vi 4°
hier drin ja wir sind jetzt hier drin im
snowdome hier findet die ganze Magie
statt wir haben eine 300 m lange Piste
300 m man kann hier Snowboard fahren man
kann hier Skifahren man kann hier sogar
einen Schlitten ausleihen und dort an
der Seite runterfahren das meiste was
mir jetzt aber im ersten Moment Angst
macht ist dieses sheilift Teil du musst
dich da irgendwie mit dem Hintern drauf
setzen und dann wirst du gezogen ich
hoffe das ist noch nicht Teil meiner
Stunde ich verbringe auch gerne hier
Zeit ich üb hier Ski sitzt safety first
hat Samira gerade schon gesagt meine
komm warte oh ich geb dir mal den Ton so
test test hallo hi das ist Samira wir
haben uns gerade schon auf Camp V
kennengelernt ja Mensch schön dass wir
uns hier getroffen haben und der Schnee
liegt hier das ganze Jahr über als ob
man in so einer riesen Kühlkammer wä ne
auf jeden Fall wir nennen ihn auch gerne
heidegletscher oder den Kühlschrank also
es ist tatsächlich so dass wir hier das
ganze Jahr dann Unterricht machen und im
Sommer dann auch mal so bisschen
trainieren und so okay schon ganz cool
also wir nehmen den Ski also a ganz kurz
zur Mission heute ich versuche heute an
einem Tag Skifahren zu lernen glaubst Du
ja und wir starten jetzt erstmal mit
einer ganz einfachen Übung du ziehst den
Ski an indem du vorne die Fußspitze
quasi so unterhakst ja und dann drückst
du mit ein bisschen mehr Gewicht auf
deiner Ferse hinten drauf achten dass
der Fuß gerade ist ja und feste drücken
richtig jawoh bist klick macht okay so
jetzt fangen wir mal an uns hier in der
Ebene zu bewegen du schiebst dich immer
ab Biss du wie so ein wchelner
Pinguin das sieht nicht heftig aus aber
das ist
echt das war mein erstes Mal dass ich
mich mit schieren fortbewegt habe es ist
so krasses
Gefühl große Schritte am Anfang re ist
halt einfach wie Fahrradfahren oder
Schwimmen lern TR irgendwann hinten auf
deinen eigenen Ski und dann legst Dich
lang man merkt gar nicht dass es hier
drin 4° sind ne wir machen ja wie gesagt
auch Sport und wenn man dann noch ein
bisschen nervös ist am Anfang dann wird
einem schnell warm ich habe irgendwie
das Gefühl dass ich diese Schuhe noch so
mit meinen Füßen mitgreifen muss aber
muss ich ja sind ja bben fest die sind
ja eigentlich fest wenn du die richtige
Größe hast ja ja die sind fest aber ich
habe irgendwie aus ich hab will ich will
die immer so nach vor also ich will die
so mitgreifen so da haben wir
verschiedene Schritte geübt um den Berg
raufzukommen um vom skelift zum nächsten
zu kommen und so das ist ein wichtiger
Schritt da Wachen gerade Muskelgruppen
auf die im Winterschlaf waren haha
Winterschlaf weil wir hier in den Bergen
sind aber so weit muss man ja nie wie
kommen wir denn jetzt gleich wieder
runter na ja fahren würde ich sagen komm
ein Stück schaffst du noch und dann
rutschen wir schon mal das erste Stück
Gewicht nach vorne ein bisschen
anschieben und einfach rutschen lassen
mach deine Hände nach vorne damit die
nicht so rumschlackern und du wirst ja
nicht mal schnell und jetzt geht's das
erste mal runter den Berg bei Samira
sieht das so leicht
[Musik]
aus
tada und jetzt du und einfach Hände nach
vorne Bauch anspannen bisschen ich fah
schie ich fahr nicht Ski ja nicht an
nicht ja super auch die möglich spring
als Kind geguckt
so damit wir nicht noch mehr in
Schwitzen geraten fahren wir jetzt mal
mit dem Förderband und dann fahren wir
noch mal runter dann fahren wir noch mal
run üben mal bremsen und sowas SAS
wichtiges und was hast du gerade gelernt
wie können wir jetzt diese kleine Hörde
hier über wir gehen in die Kante und
dann ja wscheln wieder hoch genau so
seitw so so sagt man das in fachch
Treppen steigen super hier bin ich genau
dann schiebst du dich bis vorne an die
Kante
was haben wir heute gelernt ganz weit
vorne bleiben also geht auch das
Förderband weil sonst reißt es nicht
nach hinten wollen wir natürlich nicht
also schiebst du dich bis hier vorne an
die Kante du schiebst dich drauf und
bleibst einfach stehen bis du oben
wieder auf so einem Teppich wie hier
angekommen bist und dann gehst du
vorsichtig zur Seite schieb dich ruhig
noch ein Stück nach vorne ich glaube an
dich das wird das sieht nicht nach viel
aus aber ich war so
aufgeregt schieben schieben schieben
Gewicht nach
vorne
ich richtige Panik im
Gesicht nach
vorne Knie und das ist auch so eine
unnatürliche Position Knie nach vorne
und Poo
rein das war der Hugel gell ja genau
jetzt wartest du noch moment du wirst
auf den Teppich geschoben und jetzt
gehst du zügig zur Seite genau
[Musik]
das fingerk es war schlimm es war
schlimm aber ich habe es geschafft weil
ich bin eine Kämpferin so jetzt wollen
wir ja Fahren und Bremsen üben und
gerade wenn man sich in anfängergebieten
unter also bewegt macht man das mit dem
Schneeflug bei Kindern sagt man auch
gerne Pizza vielleicht hast du schon mal
gehört er hat schon 30 mal gesagt ah
[Musik]
gucka du RST noch nicht mal
tief durchatmen okay Rücken gerade und
jetzt langsam schon mal bremsen mehr
mehr meh
kin genau was sag zu meinem
Schneeanzug cute
ne bestim ich ein bisschen Yoga mache ne
für die Körperhaltung mit Sicherheit
ja also von der Körperform habe ich das
Gefühl komplett besuert aus ja man muss
erstmal klar kommen ne also bevor man
überhaupt auf so ein Berg kommen kann
muss man irgendein Gefühl für diese Shia
bekommen es ist einfach als ob man so
schwimmen oder Fahrradfahren lernen muss
das ist etwas ganz
anderes wenn ich das jetzt so sehe das
sieht halt nicht heftig aus aber es hat
sich sehr krass angefühlt der ganz
Körper muss einfach neue Bewegungen
kennenlernen ein ganz anderes Gefühl ist
das Fresse Zitrone
no
[Musik]
ye das war nicht schlecht
ne Spitze okay jetzt ma kurz
[Musik]
pauseuse sorry ich habe mich hier auf
der pausenbank
ausgeruht was war das eigentlich für ein
reveal so Pause vorbei wir machen jetzt
weiter es geht auf die große
Piste ich habe bisschen versucht was zu
essen aber Essen war nicht so lecker es
tut mir leid bisbing das solltet ihr
noch mal ran trotzdem hat uns das die
Laune nicht kaputt gemacht denn wir
haben Bock so jetzt ging es endlich auf
den großen Berg und der Schlepplift den
musste ich jetzt bewältigen Bo ich
lieb's ja und damit ich nicht vom
schlepple Falle haben wir erstmal geübt
aber ich bin ziemlich zuversichtlich
dass du nicht rausfallen wirst wenn du
dich daran hältst einfach stehen zu
bleiben geradeaus zu guucken und dich
des Lebens zu freuen dass du jetzt
endlich den großen Berg bezwingen kannst
ja und dann ging es
[Musik]
los ja nee da du bleibst da ich musste
nur den M wieder we ach so ach so ach
ach und dann stellst du dich gerade hin
guckst nach oben und dann ging es
losiner den GrESt du komm Vanessa du
kannst es Greif ihn Greif ihn unter den
Hintern und los ge los
ja stehen bleiben
amazing ein kleiner Schritt für die
Menschheit aber ein großer Schritt für
Vanessa eigentlich gar kein Schritt für
die Menschheit die Menschheit hat
absolut nichts davon mira hat gesagt du
hättest dich auch mit einem Schlitten
auf de Schlitten setzen können und nicht
hochziehen lassen
[Musik]
können ich habe
Angst
[Musik]
Skifahren ist
das wir sind erstmal so ein bisschen
runtergestiegen weil die Steigung oben
zu krass war das ist
allesbeine
aniety die Panik ich hatte so Angst ich
meine es sieht wirklich nicht krass aus
aber eine falsche wegung und du rast
halt nach unten und wirst immer
schneller und du musst es schaffen dich
selbst zu stoppen und da bin ich
einfach ich bin da komplett einfach
runter gerast weil ich das nicht mehr
anwenden konnte was sie mir gesagt hat
und dann war ich so okay ich muss jetzt
einfach Geschwindigkeit und runter wir
können schon mal sagen ich habe es jetzt
eigentlich schon mal geschafft ich bin
runtergekommen ich bin ein bisschen noch
zu schnell aber daran arbeiten wir jetzt
noch ein bisschen daran arbeiten wir
jetzt noch ein bisschen und Timo holt
sich jetzt auch seine SK und dann ja
filmst du mal mit ein bisschen mit der
GoPro also bis gleich so meine würde
habe ich jetzt dort
reingepackt ich habe mich zweimal
hingepackt und dann war ich so ein
bisschen überfordert mit der ganzen
Situation hab dann abrupt aufgehört Timo
mag nicht wie dieses Video geendet hat
aber ich sag mal so als Fazit nein man
kann nicht an einem Tag Skifahren lernen
man lernt auf jeden Fall die
grundlegenden Dinge und man schafft es
schon mal so ein Berg runter zu aber um
wirklich sicher skief fahren zu können
muss man das mindestens eine Woche getan
haben ich hab bisschen
geweint ich bin so enttäuscht von mir
dass ich hingefallen bin ich habe
irgendwie zum Ende hinedacht yeah jetzt
kann ich es wirklich aber ich habe halt
wirklich eine starke Seite wo ich gut
Kurven machen konnte und auf der anderen
hat das halt immer überhaupt nicht
funktioniert was ich vorhatte und ich
bin immer voll schnell gewesen und dann
halt auch zweimal gegen diese Wand da
gefahren ich hätte ein bisschen stronger
sein sollen ich hätte das jetzt nicht so
ab beenden sollen haben mir auch die
Beine wie getan und meine Muskeln und so
ich B einfachch einfach so ein richtiges
Kind also in solchen Situation bin ich
richtiges Kind ich habe auch nicht so
voll geheult ich habe so mir nicht me so
drehen und ich war völlig
überfordert ja aber ansonsten vielen
Dank bis Bing war super toll vielen Dank
an Samira du warst eine so coole SK
Lehrerin mit dir hat es super viel Spaß
gemacht und ich kann Samira auch nur ans
Herz legen also wenn ihr mal in bisbing
Skiunterricht nehmen wollt fragt nach
Samira ja und jetzt gehen wir nach Hause
ne Timo du bleibst noch hier ich habe
dir ein Zimmer im Hotel Resort gebucht
räumst du weg
g tschüss Leute wir sehen uns morgen bei
vlogness Tag